Rocko's these Korean tacos but the line
is [ __ ] through the roof and I was
like yeah and he goes you know Roy right
and I went yeah and he goes can you text
him and get let him know that we're here
and I go sure my text Roy Roy says I'll
find him and so I text Steve back me go
he's looking for you and Steve goes I'm
looking for him
what does he look like and I write back
he's Korean and he goes I know what they
look like and I go like you but more hip
hoppy he's like no but describe him I go
olive skin black hair
he's [ __ ] green how you describe I go
just look for yourself but like cooler
and then all of a sudden he goes I would
never mind I found him hip hoppy is it
good let me ask you something when they
say Asian people look alike do you
believe in that Stuart no I know I don't
but that's only because eration oh but I
will tell you this our best friend's
raisin and their daughter her daughter
tried out for the softball team in her
school and she comes home she goes I'm
concerned I'm not gonna make the team
when we go we're all out in her house we
go why she goes because there's another
girl there's another Asian girl that
actually really looks like me mom and
she sucks I'm afraid they're gonna
confuse us okay and then they go and
then she goes actually the girls not
that bad so they're equally talented and
they're the same height and they look
identical Wow
and so the girl our friend's daughter
made the team and then she we go you
made the team she goes yeah but I had to
go up to the coach you go did you get
the right Asian I don't think I used to
have a joke about that and then I go
mice you ever see the same person twice
in one day
I saw this Asian lady 15 times in one
day she was everywhere she was the
cleaners she was at the nail salon she
she won't cut me off in traffic three
times yeah and so and then and then
someone told me sup my friends said you
know it was Asians yes you know we don't
all look like and then I started hanging
out with Asian people I was like they
don't look at all
thank you like it's but I will say this
when we were in Scandinavia I would
confuse blond people like crazy
like it like same
your color can throw me I thought that's
happened with me with a lot of people oh
I do have a theory about when they say
Asians are bad drivers here's my theory
my theory and it goes bad a theory too
but it goes back to to the fact that
there are so many Asians it's not the
Asians are bad drivers is that there's
so many Asians that percentage is high
you're gonna run into more bad driver
the stereotype is not it's actually not
is derived from here yes exactly because
no there's not like there's only 4% of
the population here difference no you're
not you're okay you're 4% of the
population here yeah but you're not in
the middle of the country you're only
like nine cities and it's all on the
coast [ __ ] I think that Asians are over
skilled so if you go to the Philippines
I'm telling you everyone there are no
road rules all the traffic lights are
broken so everyone sort of knows how to
use their when they honk it's like Morse
code it's very famous every everybody
zipping past everybody and I think that
that level of skill does not apply to
the infrastructure here no here's what
it is that level of skill I kind of like
that I agree like that okay that's I
agree with that good kalila but because
if you can't drive in the Philippines
you're frightened it's scary and you
what I'm saying is if you take a regular
ol American white guy they think he's
straight-up stupid stupid when he drives
in though oh I would be I'd be like have
my blinker on we don't use in other
countries they don't care that much
about their cars like oh listen to what
I'm saying is there I'll and it's go
ahead let's go I was in Thailand I saw
two cab drivers hit each other they put
their head out the window and they
looked at the car sir okay it's fine
let's move on and they kept driving my
point is is that it's not that big of
you if you get a like a little scratch
here in America yeah you pull over you
know mean you call people all that stuff
it's like in Asia we don't give that
much a [ __ ] about you're right
yet is the car still work move on to do
that make sense yeah oh I want to go to
the Philippines bad you know what they
want you there so badly
and I'm not kidding you I was actually
just talking to Mike Berta Lina and you
would have the absolute best time
they're gonna roll out the most
luxurious red carpet for the guys we
know the guys wanna I want to go see
another and they have a really large
amazing venue there what do you want to
do I never played there either you want
to do a double show that's I will
absolutely set it up I'm being real I'm
being very realize you got to bring your
kids they would love it there the hearts
are beautiful oh yeah you'll love it